foreign
San Antonio Texas hey Paula how are you
it's fine Dave and you better than I
deserve what's up
that's me however I'm trying to find out
if I'm doing the right thing for
continuing my situation I'm not trying
to be an Elon Musk or a Bill Gates I'm
very happy at what I got and I'm just
want to live comfortable and I'm doing
that but I have my mortgage paid off
I am 76 years old
and I don't work I could but I don't I
just choose not to
I have a 2600 a month Social Security
coming in I have over a hundred thousand
dollars in the money market
I have 31 000 in a savings
and I save a thousand dollars a month my
bills are all paid at the first of every
month
am I doing the right thing
okay so you have no Investments at all
no uh that's right now I am too scared
of that with the market so fallible and
everything going haywire I don't want to
play with the market okay I just want to
be comfortable and happy and and
basically I am I just want to know if
that's going to carry me through to my
you know I'm I'm 70 I'm a young 76 year
old but you're not using the money
no absolutely if you continue like you
continue it would carry you on to 176.
well I plan to live that I know I can
tell I can tell so me too more interview
than a 60 year old no I'm serious that
you're not using the money and so no you
know it's if you were burning it if you
were going through it a little bit if
you're you know eating a thousand
dollars a month out of it uh to live but
you're living on your Social Security is
what you're saying I'm living on it and
still have money sitting in my bank yeah
okay I mean if that makes you happy I'm
not going to change it
no I'm happy doing it I just want to
know if I'm if that's really the right
thing to do for me
it sounds like it is because it's what
makes you happy
you know if it was me and uh you know
I'm 62. I've got my uh money in excess
of an emergency fund uh if I had that
extra hundred thousand I'm I am
investing it into some good mutual funds
that have a long stable track record
um because I'm not scared of the market
and that would not cause me to lay awake
at night but it sounds to me like that
that would cause you to lay awake at
night so you shouldn't do it
well it would because you see everything
going up and down up and down and all
the predictions that we're going to have
a crash and all this you know right I
mean let's just I mean you you and I are
old enough that we've heard that every
year our entire life
and it never happened
well I don't I I believe what you're
saying but
those kinds of no
but no can there's always there or your
bank can go broke
yeah yeah and that's
more is in a money market Choice Money
Market now if the banks go broke or I
know it's it's federally insured or is
it with a bank
well actually it's with a savings uh a
credit union
they've got ncua so yeah that's it I
never get those that quick but uh you've
got the same you know you've got
insurance on the money if the credit
union goes belly up and then the
government would have to go belly up
which is possible too
oh yeah the way they act yeah and then
you would not get your money and so that
you know that's your absolute worst case
scenario now and if you invest the money
uh it could go up and down up and down
up and down uh but likely you know
there's no track record of it
disappearing either so but I I I'm not
gonna push on it I mean uh Paula this is
making you happy yeah and you're safe I
just want to be sure I'm kind of doing
the right thing because like I said I
put back well it's costing it's costing
you about ten thousand dollars a year
it's costing me ten thousand a year yeah
if it was invested you'd be making about
a 10 rate of return on average in good
mutual funds and on a hundred thousand
that's ten thousand dollars a year so
you're missing out on about ten thousand
dollars a year but you know it sounds to
me like it sounds to me like that's an
insurance policy causes you to sleep and
I'm not going to argue with you about it
well that's that's what I wanted to know
then you know that's all I needed to
know that I'm kind of okay with where
I'm at then you're not going to go broke
you're more than okay Paula you couldn't
do something dumb with money if you
tried I just don't think she's got it in
her name she's so wise well I mean the
thing is this now let's just talk back
up and talk about it number one that's
her situation and her and her I don't
think in one radio conversation I'm
going to cause her to have peace with
investing but I will challenge all of
you out there to the tune of ten
thousand dollars a year
uh to me that means it's time for me to
learn something and
um now when she bought her home
house prices go up and down
she did not get a guarantee from the
federal government or the ncua
our house price could go down tomorrow
but she's not concerned about that you
know why most of us when we buy home we
don't think about the fact that it's not
federally guaranteed the reason is track
record track record matters
it does and we you know we were just
going through this all the Ramsay
personalities walking through it with
you uh in a room and we were looking at
this crazy awesome uh poster essentially
that they opened up wide and they showed
the history of the stock market and they
showed how it did
before and after some of the biggest
events in American history when you
would think it would create a lot of
fear and instability and it did short
term but then it always came back and I
think that was one of the most powerful
illustrations I'd ever seen on what you
teach and what you have been teaching
well and track record is the thing why
are you comfortable buying a home with
no guarantee no federally insured
guarantee right because homes if you got
walking around sense of generally gone
up over the scope of your life I mean
first house I sold when I was 18 years
old was 42 thousand two hundred fifty
dollars to a kid from my high school now
that kid wasn't smart he bought a house
from an 18 year old but anyway
um yeah but I and you know turned out to
be a really smart idea because that
house today would probably be 350 400
000 right sure but that's a long time
ago but I mean we've all got walking
around since we can look and say okay
the track record of real estate is I'm
not going to lose all my money it might
have a little bump in the road or two
but I'm not gonna lose all my money and
if you actually look at the stock market
you know with good mutual fund investing
good Diversified investing you're not
going to lose all your money there's
gonna be some bumps in the road and
you're gonna make money and that's the
truth but you need to get comfortable
with that track record in that history
like you did that piece of real estate
and then you can sleep at night never
invest because Dave Ramsey said to
always invest never invest because
anybody said to except you you need to
get comfortable with it you need to
understand what you're putting money in
and then when you understand that
history I got a lot of Peace about
putting money in the market no trouble
for it no trouble with it for me at all